こんにちははじめ社長ですちょっと前の
動画だったんですけど僕見えるな壁正解
繕いと両国食房を使って正解市黒井部屋を
つくりましたまだ動画を見てない人だって
いたりお腹を見てくださいちょっとだけ
映像を見せしますどうぞ
あっちょっと待ってい
年前で待ってください
ずっといたらあとはおいしくなるぞこれ
アイアンはこの動画でなら大変好評という
かなんかすごいみたいなとめくって
いただきまして本当
嵐やなんか本当にすごいですよ何か入っ
たらライト熱い2ずにまクロム光の反射が
極端に少ないという本当になので真っ暗と
いうかまくるってこともアフターし不思議
な空間暗黒物質ルームと呼んでいますが8
倍に上がってきてしまったんですけども
青海地区部屋に対する最強のライバル準備
しましたこちらっ
[音楽]
正解者からイベントです
どうなっちゃうんだどうなっちゃんという
ことで今回準備ました裏普通ライトのため
にこんな箱ないようなかなり厳重でか
やばいする方法ですね
尊い濃いんですよ世界じゃあカビれた
パットに怖いですよもう高行くらい物質
出すと配置をやってみたいこと言ったって
シンプルで世界一くらい取れるられた世界
つくるヘアで j 回転さはいかない
くらいネットを開けたらどうなるのか見て
いきたいとおもいます俺で去勢回ちっ黒い
と世界ツアーとレグ戦うわけですから
ちょっと全く勝敗が付きませんがどうなっ
ちゃうんでしょうか世界 the
curry rice 動画でも問題が
使ったことあるんですけどもこちら10万
ルーメンてくれております実践ちょっと
世界2大どっちから見てみたいと思います
グレー
スイッチョンっ
つかない感じ
それはそれで困るなあああ
いやー
まぶしい
んじゃない
どうやってません皆さんもエヴァモーター
機会が続きなモーターバイクカメラだいぶ
使う
うーわー
クリアー
[音楽]
のファンの空すごい7やばいな日目
皆さん世界じゃあからいないとこうなっ
ちゃいますもうこれだこれがずーっとこれ
が稼ぎで他のまで暗くてるって言うすごく
さん入ったそれでこの10番目世界時代
から以来の思って探し黒い入っていきたい
とおもいます
黒行こう
アイドル世界に住む部屋の前に来ました
はいカメラの接点を持つです割と明るめに
出兵しております入っては一つに分けます
ね
tan
こワイヤーいつ入ってもすごいよ
大
部屋の外外空間なぜ完全に行くわとすると
こんな感じになっています一応照明つける
とこれぐらいのために良いですけど勉強し
てみます
電気9ただバックなんだよ
[音楽]
はい
何も見えませんねん
はぁ
いやーすごいなぁ
いつ来てる右中段という食べてめっちゃ
買いたいと思っています
[拍手]
dan
[音楽]
早速
世界探りたいとこの世界一くらいですか
どうなるんだろう一中カメラの設定も自動
じゃないので暗いものにあったけなから
良いものにあったりしませんもうあるが
ままの姿を映し出すと思いますで早速つけ
ていきたいとおもいます
だーっいただきます
シーンって
ああああああ
[音楽]
her too
2分
これちょっと
ん
そうなエロいぞ
すごいふうちゃん tan
ねえみてください皆さんもうピッチャーも
見えてみるねー
もーっ
ハリー
するとこの黒なんですけどもつけます
me
10万るーみるとこんな感じでありますね
まだ10万ルーメンです max です
すごいめっちゃ各だよもう
てやっ
白いけどすごいみたいなナニコレうわぁ
テントつの鞘が
な部屋の封じられるとのカレーが大意味が
わかんねえぜ
内航猿ましたーーー
広告でもそんなするファンブックロー
goo
そういう感じな部分だやっぱすごいだーっ
アン目がついてみたいああ
すごいことが分かりましたいやーで起きる
と洪水バック等で戻るんでマジでラインと
は強いんだと思いますだけど検証結果です
市外神黒い家で描いちゃリーダーをつける
と明るすぎて真っ白になるでしたいやー
すごい何でもまだないがいろんなことでき
そうだねこんなあああっっカーペットラグ
しコメント欄で教えてくださいもう
そろそろ何かやっていございますじゃあ
ん
立っはぁ
はぁ
おっ
ん
rar